Of course, as an architect, I'm interested in houses...
...and traditionally in England that's how they look like.
They all look similar with very thick walls to keep the cold out...
...and you can't tell much from the outside.
That's a little bit the preconception I have of British people: cold and reserved.
But actually, people are quite warm.
I was working as an architect back in Brazil...
...and I always wanted to work with sustainable architecture,...
...and I couldn't find a course that was as good as the one I found here.
England was more inviting in many ways.
It's a very international country where everyone meets, where other worlds meet.
I arrived towards the end of 2004, found everything so different from what I expected and never left.
British people and the British society are quite traditional in many ways,...
...but it's also a step forward in many other ways.
So, for example, for energy efficiency in housing, it's a step ahead of everyone.
The government is now trying to push into having all the new houses in Britain should be zero carbon by 2016...
...and that's just six years from now.
That's very close and that's a huge challenge.
It's one of the things we're trying to address here.